so meiner Mutter Anfrage fühlen sie sich
auch so seltsam leer die letzten neuen
50 Stunden so lange ist jetzt genau her
dass Angela Merkel und verlassen hat was
für eine Zäsur in ganz Deutschland gab
es spontane Aktionen um Merkels Politik
der letzten 16 Jahre zu feiern tausende
von Autos hielten auf der A3 und
gedachten unserer kaputten Infrastruktur
der ICE Prinz Eugen kam statt 45 + 20
Minuten zu spät das Kraftwerk Datteln 4
verbrannte Merkel zu Ehren 2000 Tonnen
Steinkohle zusätzlich und das deutsche
Internet ach nee das war wie immer
alles gesagt natürlich hat Frau Merkel
und souverän durch die ein oder andere
Krise geführt leider deckt aber die
aktuelle also Corona ziemlich brutal auf
was alles liegen gelassen wurde die
letzten Jahre kein deutscher
Regierungschef hat jemand so viele
Umfrage in Auftrag gegeben und ständig
die Stimmung im Volk zu fühlen kaum
einer hat so viel Hass auf sich gezogen
wie Merkel 2015 mir schreiben übrigens
ständig Zuschauer du System Note dir
schreibt doch die Merkel die Texte und
jetzt kann ich sehen ja sagen das ist
völlig richtig heute zum letzten Mal
hallo macht sie sehr sehr gut ab nächste
Woche müssen wir selber Regierungs hören
ein fall auf einer Art werde ich sie
tatsächlich vermissen wirklich z.b. die
wunderbare Kälte mit der sie dem
Niedergang ihrer Union in den letzten
Monaten teilnahmslos verfolgt hat
20%
im Sommer gefragt hat wo sie am
Wahlabend sein wird sagte Merkel
ungerührt
wow die Partei deren Mitglied ich bin
das ist wahre Liebe möglicherweise die
späte Rache dafür wie man sie am Anfang
ihrer Karriere in der CDU behandelt hat
als exotisches Ost Petersilien
Sträußchen für School cabinet damals der
Gipfel an Diversität Frau und Ossi
gefüllt 3 Minuten später hat sie den
ranzigen Verein aber mal schön auf links
gedreht und Gegner politisch
verschwinden lassen und reihenweise bis
hin zur quasi Alleinherrschaft in
Vollendung zu beobachten bei der
sirenensichel legendären Zähne vom
Wahlabend 2013 wo sie Hermann Gröhe das
Fähnchen Weg nimmt die Sonne im Faltens
auffälligen dreijährigen der zum ersten
Mal eine Cola getrunken hat wunderbar es
bleibt in der Rückschau also auch
durchaus Schönes z.b. Angela Merkels
ausgeprägte und Eitelkeit ihr
Pragmatismus und dass sie immer top
vorbereitet und voll im Thema Bar wenn
du dich hier
rhetorisches Talent na ja wir haben
inzwischen mehr
Migranten die auch einen Schulabschluss
machen es sind immer noch zu viele
ich behaupte in Wirklichkeit kennen wir
die Frau gar nicht nach all den Jahren
es heißt z.b. ohne Kameras hätte sie
einen richtig guten Humor wirklich das
berichten Insider angeblich kann sie
Kolleginnen und Kollegen perfekt
parodieren ab jetzt nur noch privat
diese Woche hat sie nämlich ihre
Kanzlerin Büro geräumt und stellen sich
vor wir haben tatsächlich Welt exklusive
Bilder davon hier sie hat erst die ganze
Ahnenreihe der von ihr abgesägten unions
Männer abgehängt den Hörer vom Kanzler
Telefon mit Senf eingeschmiert albern
noch einmal die Grenze für Flüchtlinge
aufgemacht nun die AFD zu ärgern und zum
Schluss ein paar gehässige Graffitis an
die Wand gesprüht als kurzen Gruß an die
Ampel übrigens die Grenze war nie zu
also auch gar nicht aufmachen
Angela Merkel
ein klarer Fall für irgendwen mit
Medienträger mit Medien mit Friedrich
Küppersbusch
riesen Rummel diese Woche in den Medien
noch einmal um unsere scheidende
Kanzlerin und Liebe Vogue ist bei
anderes Pack den Begriff scheidende
Kanzlerin bitte nicht gern an der Tür
direkt in die Hölle also merke jetzt
sogar als werbemaskottchen für Haarspray
für IKEA also eigentlich alle machen
Werbung mit Merkel außer natürlich der
CDU der OBI Biber hat schon richtig
Angst um seinen Job vor lauter halt
immer sehen die Medien dabei allerdings
einen wichtigen Aspekt sich selbst und
sie schon mal gefragt wie es sein kann
Merkel als Medien Wunder dass jemand der
36 Jahre also mehr als im kompletten
baerbock in einer Diktatur lebt auf
Knopfdruck die freien Medien virtuos
beherrscht also nicht beherrscht sondern
beherrscht
[Musik]
als letzte Regierungssprecherin der DDR
verscheuchte merke noch die
aufdringlichen Westmedien doch bald
randalierte sie selber dort Fernsehen
was hat das mit der Klimakonferenz
Telefonnummer Stimmen
wurde Merkel
[Applaus]
sehr und stehe ich richtig super also
dann los
liebe Fans der fallston Unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take wir haben sie auch
echt schicke aus heute